Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and create
the grunge layered material and the material layer blend
to bring it all together.
So let's get started.
Now in the previous video, we went in here
and we created our tile setup, and we kept it pretty simple.
Now again, this can be anything
that you want it to be.
And let's go ahead and expose that last one
we kind of forgot about.
Let's go and put our tile texture,
or you can just call it albedo.
And we have everything exposed.
And let's go and expose that last one here,
which would be our normals.
Looks like we already got it, my bad.
So we got everything set up with this one.
Let's go ahead and build our grunge,
or what we could use for a grunge.
And we have the material already set up,
if you followed along in the last video.
And let's go and double click on that one.
He's off screen, so let's bring him over.
There we go.
And we're going to kind of repeat the last process
we had before.
It's going to be pretty simple stuff.
So we're going to go ahead and create
a make material attributes.
So make material attributes.
There we go.
Place that right here.
Plug that right into that input material attribute.
There we go.
And again, they act like material functions.
They kind of act as a gateway to be
able to customize the material any way that we want.
And we're going to go ahead and pull in the grunge.
Now this grunge can be anything that you choose.
I'm going to choose the t underscore grime.
So I'm going to keep my finger on the t key, left click,
and we're going to go ahead and look for t, inner details
t underscore grime.
There it is, diffuse.
We've got a couple of locations for it.
We'll just grab this one.
We also need another one for normal,
so I'll keep my finger on the t key, left click.
And we'll do under the details t underscore,
again, g for grime.
Let's do ri to get more populated in there
in our search.
And then we'll grab the normal and punch it in here.
Now again, this can be anything that you want.
So if you want to, and what I mean by that,
you can add as much as you need in these slots, whatever
fits the scenario.
And I'm going to keep my finger on the m key again.
And I'm going to keep my finger on the s key.
And this will be the scaler.
So this will be normal amount.
And this is going to be known as our grime.
So because we're going to have a couple of normal amounts.
So if they pop up, put that here, put that over here.
And then we're going to put this right in here.
Now if you want to do the same thing,
there'll be two we can I'm going to save that last step.
I'm going to grab that multiply here
and put that right into the normal there.
There we go.
And we'll just hit apply.
So we know that that guy's working.
And the last one here, we'll hit apply to
that guy's working too.
Now you typically you'll hit save.
But since I use this file quite often,
I'm not going to hit save on this one.
So we know what we have our two material blends
ready to go.
Or layers, I should say.
Now we need to go into the material layer blend.
Now in my notes,
it talks about how going we can go straight
to the parent material, which we will.
But in this case, we're going to go to the blend first
because it's just a little easier to work with.
And I think you can follow along a little bit better here
because you may get some errors
if you start trying to plug things in.
Without that material layer blend,
that thing's kind of important.
So I'm going to go ahead
and double click on our material.
It's off screen.
So let me go and pull that over.
There we go.
And we're going to go ahead and build this out.
And we're going to make this
a little bit more complicated.
Then I have two different versions in my slides.
One that's super simple and it fades it in and out
kind of like you saw with the Megascans example.
But we want to have it
so that the grunge punches through.
So we're going to have some fun with this.
So let's go ahead and pull up the texture that we need.
So we're going to go in and grab,
let's go and keep a finger on the T key and left click.
And I'm going to go in here
and grab a T grunge roughness.
So T underscore grunge roughness.
We'll use this one.
And again, you can use any one that you want.
There's another one, which is old school.
It's been sitting in Unreal for so long.
Keep my finger on the T key, left click.
This one's actually called T underscore UDK.
If you are an old school Unreal person,
you'll know UDK was the first free version.
And you can use this guy too.
The only problem is at the very bottom,
there's a clip off here where you have no texture
and it's kind of odd.
So I don't, I just point people to this.
I don't necessarily use this all the time.
So just wanted to point that out.
So you could do that because that's in my example.
We're going to move this over here.
Now, what we want to do is blend things in such a way
that we're grabbing and you'll notice we have,
let me go full screen for a second.
You'll notice we have this input bottom and input top.
So they act like material functions,
these material attributes here.
They actually house the layers as they fall into the parent.
And I'll show you how to do that.
And it actually acts as gateway
so that we can populate these areas.
We really don't have to do anything with them,
but we're going to have to mess with the alpha
if we want these textures to blend a particular way.
So what we're going to have to do
is I'm going to pull this down
and I'm going to call up a clamp
because it just keeps things within a range.
Now you can punch in the numbers, anything that you want.
You'll see where automatically get an error.
It doesn't show up in our stats.
That's because we don't have anything to climb.
So it's like, what are you doing?
So I'm kind of doing this a little bit backwards,
but we're going to go ahead and populate that.
So let's go and move this back for a second.
Don't panic.
If you got an error,
I just want to get you started in the right direction.
I'm going to pull this texture over.
And what we're going to do is hit the M key
and the left click.
And that's going to give us our multiplying.
And then I'm going to go and attend
and using a scaler to intensify that.
Keep my finger on the ask key, get this here.
And we'll call this a grunge intensity.
I'm not going to bother grouping these
because you kind of get the idea how to do that.
You should know that by now.
Just to save a bit of time.
And I'm going to go ahead and put this default to one.
We can set that to maximum to five if we want to
and give the minimum zero.
I'm going to pull that string right into the B channel,
grab this texture sample,
pull it into the A channel there.
Now we're going to grab this multiply
and we want to be able to control
not only just the intensity, but the contrast.
So we're going to go and keep,
I'm going to go and create a power node.
There we go.
And this power node allows us,
and I'm real so great with the prototypes.
It takes two inputs and raises the base
to the exponential power and outputs the result.
So it actually gives us a little control here
so we can actually almost like a multiply and steroids.
You're going to go that way.
Allows us to grab this here as the base
and then exponentially we can increase that information.
So we're going to go to and create a scaler again.
There we go.
And we're going to make this guy the contrast.
Contrast grunge.
Awesome.
And we'll set that to one.
And again, you get the idea for grouping.
Typically I will group things and keep that.
I'll send it here, but we'll keep this just generic.
And we'll grab the power and go right into the clamp.
Oh, let's make sure we go all the way.
There we go.
Bam, it is connected.
You'll see the area go away and we should be good to go.
Now again, we'd have nothing to reference with this blend
so it doesn't know what to do.
It's not like these two material layers
which already have the plugin
and the preview is working like a champ.
Cool.
So in the next video, we're going to go ahead
and create the information that we need
for our parent material to bring this all together.
Thanks again.